yeah so your uncle passes away which uh
hurts um you have a something of an
epiphany while visiting his grave site
with your dad and then you wound up
actually starting an organization that
reconnects homeless people with loved
ones uh which has now resulted in 800
plus uh people reconnecting with loved
ones and in many cases getting off the
street so how did that come to pass I
mean that's a lot uh like happened after
you visited your uncle's grave site um
and this is at this point maybe 10 years
ago yeah it's about 10 years ago yeah I
I you know I got I left the grave site
with my dad had a really heartfelt
conversation and um realized that the
intention of kind of having this grave
site for my uncle was was really that uh
we'd have a place to commemorate Mark's
life and and have a permanent resting
place for this person who never had that
in this life and uh you know I got got
home and started scrolling through
social media and realized that you know
I was learning more about my random
acquaintances on Facebook and you know
Instagram than I was at my own uncle's
grave so I just started thinking how can
we use the storytelling tools that we
have access to to help people like my
uncle Mark um you know I'm a person of
faith and uh I was in church a few weeks
later pastor had this prompt who is
Jesus he had to answer that with some
kind of art form or creative expression
I'm not an artist I'm not a musician
Jesus doesn't need me to sing a song
but I was like well I've always loved
using simple tools to help share our
common humanity and kind of unveil what
I feel is ever presentent and I got this
question on my heart that was uh really
struck me was you know how would how
would Jesus use a
smartphone and maybe would use a
smartphone I'm kidding but if he were to
use it if he were to use it you were
probably fewer cat videos and uh selfies
right so you started this organization
um what like what what came first the
first uh beneficiary or homeless
neighbor that you helped or the
organization itself yeah I mean the
first point was um I spent a year just
listening spent a year with 24
individuals experiencing homelessness
who volunteered to wear GoPro cameras
around their chests wow and narrate
their experience of what life is like on
the streets and the premise was hey I
just walked by you you're still here
what's it like to be you uh and I watch
dozens of hours of pretty heartbreaking
footage and uh you know the two things
that struck me Andrew was uh first every
time you'd see a kid walk by the kid
would tug on their mom or dad's sleeve
they Point they'd look they'd ask
questions and half the time the parent
would would scold them and say no that's
dangerous don't do that and you know I'd
always think gosh those kids probably
knew something or know something that
we've forgotten as adults um but the
second piece that's really appropo to
Miracle messages founding story was in
one of the clips I heard someone say you
know I never realized I was homeless
when I lost my housing only when I lost
my family and friends yeah you you you
uh opened the book with this uh idea of
relational poverty um and and you're
suggesting that we're relationship poor
and that that kind of goes hand inand
with being homeless yeah I think it's so
um it's it's such an extreme version of
low Social Capital to use the
sociological term but such a level of
relational isolation Brokenness
disconnectedness that it's almost
inconceivable unless you get that up
close and personal to it um you know I
um I I read your book recently the war
on normal people and one of the things
that you really talk about at length is
how many people in the United States
right now now are one paycheck away from
not being able to pay rent um and given
the precarity of you know 40% of people
not knowing where they get $400 for an
unexpected
emergency uh it's actually surprising
that we don't have more people
experiencing homelessness in this
country like what's keeping half the
country from experiencing homelessness
and what we're finding is Family Friends
Community Church synagogue mosque like
Community relationships and so if you
don't have have that or you've lost that
or it was never quite supportive enough
or it was just so resource depressed to
begin with um you can be very difficult
to get off the streets and stay off the
streets if you're if you're in that
situation yeah you refer to this group
as the Proto homeless or maybe someone
else did which I thought was interesting
it's like the could potentially be
homeless uh if if something breaks the
wrong way um so let's try and Define the
scope of this how many people are
homeless in America at any moment in
time yeah at any given night it's just
under well depends on the estimates but
around 600,000 people experience
homelessness any given night um but over
the course of a year um people who may
come in and out of homelessness maybe
self-resolve or you know are unseen are
doubled up tripled up so maybe not what
we think of by the HUD definition as
experiencing homelessness uh you know
it's probably closer to about 10 times
that and so in the book we estimate
about 6 million people experience
homelessness each year wow it's a lot so
in a country of 330 million let's call
it something like 2% 2% M yeah one out
of 50 might experience homelessness in a
given year one interesting thing in your
book is you actually list a bunch of
celebrities who are homeless at One
Moment In Time some of them I knew I was
like oh yeah I knew juul was homeless
but but like some of the others I was
like really like I like I didn't know
who surprised you David Letterman
surprised me letter in yeah Chris Pratt
I guess there was and then I thought oh
wait there was some episode about him
living in a van or something which uh
and and I feel like vehicles are where a
lot of folks take shelter if you live in
a vehicle um like let's say your car
your Toyota Camry um are you technically
homeless yes yes you are absolutely yeah
and I I I think even within the
Celebrity Circle if we widen that to
folks who are you know Successful by
whatever measures of you know monetary
Fame power a lot more people are have
experienced homelessness than we'll will
share that they have experienced
homelessness you know I I get I I bet we
don't know about some of it um it's
totally true um so you start Miracle
messages about 10 years ago and and it
starts with this footage hours and hours
of ver footage from people who are
struggling with homelessness what did
you do next
yeah so I it started out uh just to give
the the quick founding story I basically
took a walk down Market Street went up
to everyone I saw who was visibly
homeless and ask do you have any family
or friends you'd like to reconnect to
met a man named Jeffrey he said he
hadn't seen his family in 22 years sat
down recorded a short video from him to
his niece and nephew and his sister and
his dad went home that night did a
search online found a Facebook group
connected to his hometown and uh you
know post the video there with a short
note nice
work you know just the entrepreneur and
me right just get things done right and
within one hour uh the video was shared
hundreds of times made the local news
that night uh classmates started
commenting saying hey I went to high
school with Jeffrey I work in
construction does he need a job you know
I work at the congressman's office does
he need Healthcare in a week the town
raised over $5,000 to try to bring him
home and in the first 20 minutes of the
post his sister got tagged and uh we got
on the phone the next day and she told
me that Jeffrey had been a missing
person for 12 years no so that was that
was the starting point
yeah hey YouTube glad you're enjoying
the podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank
you